- HELLO,
EVERYBODY OUT THERE.
THIS IS BROCK FAVORS
WITH TRAFFIC ON THE ONES.
CHAD ARMSTRONG
IS OUT SICK TODAY,
SO I AM FILLING IN
FROM MY USUAL LAND REPORTS.
AND, UH, I'M UP HERE
IN THE CHOPPER.
BUT I GOTTA TELL YOU GUYS,
I AM LOVING THE VIEW.
[laughs]
OH, [bleep]!
[screams]
OH, MY GOD!
OH, OH, NO!
STOP, STOP, STOP, STOP.
OH!
WHEW.
ALL RIGHT.
[chuckles]
WELL, WE ARE,
UM, UH--
WE ARE OVER THE 10.
IT IS MASSIVELY CLOGGED
DOWN THERE,
LIKE A PINT OF MAPLE SYRUP
ON A COOL NOVEMBER MORNING.
AND WE JUST--OH, [bleep]!
MOTHER-[bleep], GOD DAMN!
WE GON' DIE
IN THIS MOTHER-[bleep]!
OH, [bleep].
OH, MY GOD!
WHEW, WHEW, WHEW!
OKAY.
[chuckles]
OKAY, I AM, UH--
I AM VERY SORRY, FOLKS.
[chuckles] IT'S A LITTLE BIT
OF A BUMPY RIDE UP HERE.
WE ARE NOW APPROACHING
THE 405,
AH, WHERE THE LEFT LANE
IS BLOCKED BY A MATTRESS.
SO SOMEBODY IS,
UH, GONNA BE DOING
A LITTLE RETURN TO IKEA LATER
TODAY, YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAY--
OH, NO, [bleep], PLEASE!
[bleep]. OH, GOD DAMN!
OH, GET ME OUT THIS
MOTHER-[bleep] DEATH MACHINE
RIGHT NOW!
OH, NO!
BLACK PEOPLE AIN'T MEANT
TO BE IN THE SKY!
WE AIN'T MEANT TO BE
IN THE SKY, MAN.
[crying]
OH, MAMA, HELP ME.
MOTHER-[bleep].
OH, MAMA!
AAH, [bleep].
WELL, THE 405 IS [bleep] UP
RIGHT NOW.
AIN'T NOBODY GOING DOWN
THIS [bleep]. I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
I'M VERY SORRY, FOLKS.
I'M VERY SORRY
ABOUT THAT,
BUT I AM LOSING
MY [bleep] UP HERE.
- ACTUALLY,
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO.
WE'RE ABOUT TO CRASH.
- OH, [bleep],
HELP ME.
[bleep].
OH, MY GOD, HELP.
MAMA, PLEASE.
MAMA! HELP!
[explosion]
[upbeat music]